Der Java-Hamster ist ein Tutorial, mit dem man Java lernen kann. Es ist ein Tutorial, ich suche immer noch nach einem total super einfachen Java-Tutorial. Wenn jetzt jemand noch einen Tipp hat, außer dem Java-Hamster, bin ich total glücklich. Ich sehe die Vorteile des Java-Hamsters, aber ich denke, es kann vielleicht noch besser gehen.
Was sind denn die Vorteile des Java-Hamsters?
Es ist ein Einstieg in die Programmiersprache Java und man hat einen Hamster und man kann so eine Art Labyrinth bauen und den Java-Hamster irgendwie, ich glaube, Körner fressen lassen. Ich habe das letzte Mal irgendwie im Sommer angeguckt. Genau, das ist wie gesagt, man kann damit Java lernen, so ein bisschen die Grundlagen. Wie gesagt, ich dachte, vielleicht geht es noch ein bisschen bunter oder so.
Julio hat uns das geschrieben, man meinte, der Java-Hamster kann mittlerweile auch Python und Ruby. Das ist auch noch eine Frage, es gibt ja verschiedene Programmiersprachen und hier hätte man ja ein Beispiel, da könnte man sich ein Problem in verschiedenen Programmiersprachen gleich angucken. Jetzt frage ich mich auch gerade, ist es eh so, wenn man Programmieren anfängt, dass man eigentlich nicht eine Programmiersprache lernt, sondern wenn man eine gelernt hat, dann weiß man auch, man kann auch noch eine lernen. Dass es eigentlich sinnvoll ist, das parallel zu machen. Also nicht parallel, aber sich gleich von Anfang an darauf einzustellen, wenn ich das ernsthaft verfolgen will. Also nicht nur, wenn es mir nur um grundsätzliches Verständnis geht, sondern wenn ich es ernsthaft verfolgen will, muss ich eh damit rechnen, dass ich verschiedene Sprachen lerne?
Also man kann auch so enden wie ich und kann irgendwie 20 Sprachen so richtig schlecht am Ende. Nichts richtig. Das ist aber auch kein Hindernis. Also ich bin immer auch dafür, dass man sagen kann, ich hauptsache es funktioniert und es kommt was bei raus und ich habe ein Problem dann gelöst damit. Aber ja, es macht wahrscheinlich irgendwann, wenn man es ernsthaft betreiben will, Sinn, dass man sich irgendwie spezialisiert.
Aber ist jede Sprache sozusagen ganz was Neues? Oder ist es auch so quasi, man spricht Deutsch und kann dann Berlinern umwechseln?
Na, es ist ein bisschen so auch generell wie bei den Menschen so, wenn ich jetzt Deutsch Muttersprachlerin bin, dann fällt mir Englisch und Holländisch wahrscheinlich nicht so schwer.
Aber Finnisch, aber Finnisch.
Aber Finnisch, genau. Und dann wiederum irgendwie Hochchinesisch oder Ungarisch, ja, ist für mich total schwierig. Aber erst mal dieses Konzept zu wissen, meine Muttersprache ist eine Sprache unter vielen. Das ist glaube ich schon der Einstieg dazu, dass du überhaupt verstehst, okay, es gibt sowas wie Grammatik und es macht Sinn, sich Sprache irgendwie systematisch anzueignen. So ein Syntax.
Nee, Syntax ist das, welche Wörter es gibt und Grammatik ist in welcher Reihenfolge die Wörter erscheinen müssen, damit es valides Stück Programmcode ist.
Ich denke es gibt, vielleicht sollte man das mal in so einer Einsteigersendung auch sagen. Dass es so verschiedene Konzepte gibt. Ich glaube, so zwei große ist eben mal das objektorientierte und dann das Funktionale. Ich glaube, du kannst dazu was sagen. Erdgeist, mehr als ich auf jeden Fall.
Das eine ist irgendwie so eher imperativ, dass man hinschreibt, mach mal jetzt das und dann mach das und dann mach das. Und das andere ist so eher funktional, dass man sagt, ich hätte gerne am Ende dieses Problem gelöst. Computer, mach mal bitte das äh...
Nee, ein bisschen weniger abstrakt mal kurz.
Möchtest du hierher kommen, machst das hervorragend.
Echt schwierig, weil dieser zweite funktionale Programmieren kommt sehr krass aus der Mathematik. Deswegen, da könnte man noch mal eine eigene Sendung dazu machen. Ich glaube, das kann ich nicht kurz unterbrechen.
Ich muss ganz kurz sagen, weil ich habe Freunde, Jugendliche, die sind mir böse, wenn ich jetzt hier über Java spreche und nicht Haskell erwiene.
Okay, ne, stopp halt. Muss ich dich jetzt leider unterbrechen, weil wir gerade jetzt bei der Mathematik, da passt eine Hörerfrage, die wir per Studie-Message bekommen haben. Und zwar fragt Stefan, er hätte mal ein Buch von Norbert Wiener gelesen, anscheinend eine große Nummer irgendwie bei den Informatikern. Und er fragt jetzt, ist das mit dem Programmieren mittlerweile, also er hat das nicht so geschrieben, ich lese das heraus als die Frage, zu so einer Art Handwerkskunstverkommen? Oder hängt da auch noch sozusagen das Interesse an den höheren mathematischen Problemen, die dahinterstecken drin? Oder kann man beides machen?
Man kann Informatik machen, ohne eine Zeile zu programmieren, jemals. Also Informatik ist eine eigene Wissenschaft. Ich glaube, Norbert Wiener, das war so was in Richtung Kybernetik, irgendwie sozusagen noch bevor es Informatik gab als Begriff. Das ist eine Wissenschaft für sich. Das hat auch alles seine Berechtigung und so. Aber es muss nicht mit Programmieren einhergehen, sag ich jetzt mal so. Man kann wiederum auch programmieren, ohne auch nur die blasseste Ahnung von Informatik zu haben, bis zu einem gewissen Punkt.
Das stimmt, sehr schmerzhaft. Das merkt man auch an den Universitäten, dass dort Leute anfangen, Informatik zu studieren, die eigentlich programmieren, für ihren Beruf lernen wollen. Die wollen dann eigentlich später mal Java können, damit sie eben bei Siemens oder einer großen Firma anfangen können, irgendwo so 9 to 5 Module für irgendeine Wirtschaftsanwendung da durchzuimplementieren. Die sind eigentlich in Informatik falsch aufgehoben. Die sollten an die Fachhochschule gehen und dann Systemintegration oder halt programmieren lernen. Aber weil einfach so viele Leute bei der Informatik angerannt gekommen sind und es dann Kritik gab, dass die da Regen stehen gelassen wurden, haben sich dann auch in der Informatik in vielen Universitäten dann die Professoren dazu entschlossen, auch dort Java beizubringen.
Also ist quasi Informatik an der Uni mittlerweile sowas wie Jura, wo man sagt, das ist eigentlich eine Ausbildung und das wissenschaftliche Gerät doch ab und zu den Hintergrund?
Es gibt übrigens, möchte ich noch mal ganz kurz sagen, man muss kein Abi haben. Man kann auch zum Beispiel Ausbildung machen als Anwendungsprogrammierer. Wenn man jetzt irgendwie keinen Bock hat, Abi zu machen, es gibt auch andere Wege, Programmierer zu werden.
Ja, oder man geht zu den Rails Girls Beginners Worker. Da muss man gar nichts können.
Wir sprechen in der letzten halben Stunde noch, also ab halb zwölf nochmal genau, was es für verschiedene Programme gibt, wo man hingehen kann oder wie man das machen kann. Nicht Programme, die man programmiert, sondern Programme im Sinne von Veranstaltungen, die Programmieren, Lernen ermöglichen.
Ich würde total gerne auf deine Frage wieder zurückkommen.
Welche?
Was du bestimmt magst, mit dem sich wissenschaftlich damit auseinandersetzen. Weil es gab ja in letzter Zeit diverse Meldungen, dass gerade kritische Infrastruktur von Hackern übernommen worden ist. Und das lag daran, dass die Programmiersprache, die da benutzt worden ist, auch sehr hemmsärmlich daher kam und damals eigentlich eher so schnell Dinge erledigen sollte und wenig Augenmerk auf formale Korrektheit gelegt worden ist. Das heißt, da hat man schnell was hingeschrieben und hat die ganzen Randbedingungen ignoriert. Wird schon keiner irgendwie mal umlauter eingeben, geht schon alles. Und das macht vielleicht auf so einer Webseite, die Nachrichten ausliefert, weniger Probleme als irgendwie vielleicht wenn du eine Steuerung für dein Auto hast, wo das Bremssystem gesteuert werden soll. Da willst du eigentlich schon, dass am besten auch noch eine Art von Hardcore-Mathematikern durchbewiesen ist, dass diese Funktion tut genau das, was ich dort in meinen festen Bedingungen vorher und nachher festgelegt habe. Wenn es es nicht tut, dann ist da ein Fehler drin und das muss durchgetestet und am Ende am besten auch durch bewiesen werden. Und das kann man in einigen Programmiersprachen quasi nicht machen und in anderen Programmiersprachen die sind extra dafür angelegt worden, dass das geht. Und das sind so funktionale Programmiersprachen, weil das eben an der Mathematik stark orientiert ist und sehr formal, also die Grammatik ist sehr fest. Das heißt also, was so ein valides Programm ist, ist so wie sehr strikten Regeln unterworfen. Und damit lässt sich das am Ende auch von einem Computer beweisen, dass die tut, was sie soll. Das also gibt diverse Anwendungsbereiche in der jetzt moderne Informatik, wo wieder viel Augenmerk auf Sicherheit gelegt wird. Bekommt das wieder echt neuen Aufschwung, nachdem es zwischendurch von den hemserbenigen Programmierern, die mal schnell eine Webseite machen wollten, in den Hintergrund gedrängt worden ist. Kommt jetzt wieder wirklich Informatik im Sinne von Informatik als Wissenschaft. Kommt jetzt wieder daher. Und es wird auch wieder viel Aufmerksamkeit und Geld auf Programmierer geworfen, die Lust haben, korrekte Programme zu schreiben, die eben nicht von dem um Russischen HKA...
Gibt es eigentlich auch verschiedene Programmiererstile? Weil es gerade so hemserbenlich ist und Beweise... Ich glaube, es gibt Archetypen der Programmierung. Oder des Programmierer oder Programmiererinnen...
.dass die unterschiedlichen Programmiersprachen und Communities unterschiedliche Programmierer anziehen. Python zum Beispiel ist dafür bekannt, dass das so Leute sind, die niemanden mehr was zu beweisen haben. Du hast wie so C-Programmierer, die Linux machen, die sind meistens so noch so... Jugendliche mit viel Testosteron oder... Und Python-Programmierer sind meistens dann so, ich muss hiermit jetzt... Ich will da keinen Ärger mit haben, ich will was Abgehangenes, was ordentlich dokumentiert ist. Dokumentation ist in Python wirklich sehr wichtig. Und Python hat sich von Anfang an auf die Fahnen geschrieben, wir trieten euch ein bisschen, dass eure Einrückung und der Stil des Programms muss so sein, dass man es am Ende auch wieder leicht lesen kann. Andere Programmiersprachen sind leicht zu schreiben, aber einen Horror zu lesen, so Pearl ist dann ein Standardbeispiel. Das ist wieder ein Insiderwitz, aber das war damals, wenn du Systemadministrator warst und schnell Logfiles auswerten wolltest, dann hast du in Pearl das Pearlscript, das ist so ein stehender Begriff für unlesbaren Wust, schnell in Pearlscript zusammengehackt und die Variablen waren möglichst immer nur ein Buchstabe, möglichst viele Sonderzeichen, viel Magie, die passiert durch möglichst wenig Zeichen. Und wenn du zwei Wochen später drauf geguckt hast, dann bist du so zum Geier.
Es gab früher auch mal so einen Wettbewerb, wo es darum ging, ein Programm zu schreiben, was aussieht, als würde es eine Sache tun, aber in Wirklichkeit eine andere Sache tut. Und zwar möglichst so, dass man es möglichst nicht verstehen kann. Ich glaube, es gibt wahrscheinlich immer noch den Office-Code des... Genau. Und es gibt auch, weil du sagst, verschiedene Stile, es gibt auch tatsächlich, du kannst zum Teil anhand der Programme schon unterscheiden, wer hat dieses Programm geschrieben. Aber das nur nebenbei. Ich denke, es gibt immer einen Nutzen oder einen Zweck, wofür man irgendeine Sprache benutzt. Und danach sollte man meiner Meinung nach auch die Sprache dann auswählen. Also, wie gesagt, das sind Leute, die sich aufgegeben haben, die Python benutzen, aber das muss nicht so sein.
Nein, das sind Leute, die nichts mehr zu beweisen haben.
Das geht auch nicht. Also es gibt einfach für bestimmte Zwecke gibt es Sachen, die einfach zu lernen, gut zu benutzen sind. Und dafür sollte man die auch benutzen.
Aber gibt es, also ist alternd Programmiersprachen eigentlich? Also es gibt ja von Programmiersprachen habe ich jetzt irgendwie gelernt, auch verschiedene Versionen, aber wenn die auch alten, dann sag mal, okay, das macht man heute eigentlich nicht mehr.
Ja, ich kann noch alte Programmiersprachen wie Fortran 77, die niemand mehr benutzt aus gutem Grund. Und das sollte auch nicht mehr verwendet werden. Es gibt eben noch, ja der Grund ist eben, es gibt Libraries, es gibt Bibliotheken, die bestimmte Sachen sehr gut und sehr schnell machen. Und da gibt es dann Leute, die das wiederum noch benutzen. Oder es gibt so Legacy Code. Gibt es ja auch in Kobol irgendwie, das war irgendwie zur Jahrtausendwende so ein Problem. Sachen, die einfach niemand jemals wieder anfassen will und naja, die eben noch in einer ganz alten Sprache geschrieben sind. Aber so würde man das heutzutage nicht mehr machen. Muss man auch nicht mehr, weil die Rechner schneller sind.
Gibt es andererseits Trendsprachen? Also sozusagen die cool gefunden werden, weil also so die Fixies unter den Programmiersprachen, niemand fällt auf zu sagen, Fixies, aber das ist doch was meiner.
Ja, grad akut ist so Go und Rust wird grad gehypt. Vor fünf Jahren war Ruby der heiße aktuelle Kram. Und PHP war dann davor der heiße Kram. Und du siehst, dass da auch mal Probleme mitkommen. Weil wenn es zu sehr gehypt ist, dann hast du dieses Hammer-Nagel-Problem, dass irgendjemand dann genau ein Werkzeug gelernt hat und jetzt alle Probleme damit erschlagen möchte, ob es brauchbar ist oder nicht. Und deswegen war vorhin ging ja die Frage rum, ob man sich viele Programmiersprachen angucken sollte. Natürlich, man sollte sich erstens viele Programmiersprachen angucken. Man muss nicht unbedingt darin programmieren und viele Bibliotheken, um zu gucken, welche Sprachen bringen, welche Werkzeuge mit uns und für welches Problem vielleicht geeignet. Deswegen sich da so ein Überblick zu verschaffen ist, wenn man die Zeit hat und jetzt nicht ganz dringend was mal implementieren muss. Einfach mal durch den Garten stapfen. Der Programmiersprachen und Frameworks ist eigentlich immer eine gute Idee.
Man kann sich auch mit jemandem unterhalten.
Das ist nicht der erste Schritt. Man sollte wahrscheinlich schon eine Programmiersprache ein bisschen können, bevor man sich anguckt.
Das ist genau wie mit Sprache lernen. Also wie mit menschlichen Sprachen lernen. Du machst dir auch nicht Englisch und Französisch gleichzeitig.
Du, Nana, wolltest du noch unbedingt was zu Haskell sagen? Warum? Ist das besonders einsteigerfreundlich?
Nein, das ist wirklich eine von diesen Sprachen, die so... Also mir fällt es schwer, das zu verstehen, aber das kommt, weil ich eben nicht funktionale Programmierung gelernt habe. Es ist diese Sprache, wo er Erdgeist von berichtet hat, die eben sehr sicher ist und die für also für sicherheitsrelevante Anwendungen dann auch benutzt werden kann. Und hat eben sehr viele Vorurteile, die beispielsweise Java nicht hat.
Das sind aber, wenn wir jetzt da wieder draufgucken, sind diese Sprachfamilien ja immer orientiert an der Historie auch. Also du hast immer so Sprachfamilienklassen, wo du die Evolution beobachten kannst.
Aber das ist schon dann was für Fortgeschrittene, oder? Also Sprachfamilienklasse, die Evolution beobachten?
Es gibt große Worte dafür, dass einfach nur hat jemand wie eine neue Version erfunden und wollte nicht, dass die Leute, die die alte Programmiersprache gelernt haben, komplett wie die, wie der Ox vorm Berg stehen und nicht wissen, was jetzt tippen müssen, sondern haben dann einfach bestimmte Konstrukte, wie man Schleifen beschreibt, wie man Variablen beschreibt, haben sie einfach von der alten Sprache übernommen, auch wenn es unter der Haube dann was anderes macht. Und dann siehst du, dass einige Programmiersprachen an C orientiert sind, andere an einer älteren Sprache namens Lisp. Und hast du dann üblicherweise, je nachdem wie die Konzepte voneinander erben, also wie die Konzepte übernommen worden sind und wie bestimmte Konstrukte in der Sprache übernommen worden sind, siehst du diese Klassen dann schon. Und kannst dann einige Programmiersprachen leichter lernen, weil du schon aus der Klasse eine gelernt hast, als eine andere zum Beispiel.
Ok, also das ist tatsächlich sagen Englisch und Französisch dann vielleicht einfacher.
Ja, ich wollte nochmal, weil hier oft dann gerade gesagt wurde, irgendwie eine Sprache ist besonders leicht oder irgendwie einfach zu lernen. Und da hat mal eine Freundin von mir gesagt, dass sie das schwierig findet oder dass sie dann den Eindruck hatte, wenn sie dann was verstanden hat und andere Leute sagen, das ist total leicht, dann motiviert sie das gar nicht so sehr, weil sie dann darin ihre Bemühungen, das eben zu verstehen, da hinzukommen, irgendwie sozusagen unterschätzt sieht. Und das fand ich irgendwie ganz, also für sich, sie hat für sich gesprochen und da muss jeder für sich selbst sprechen können. Aber ich fand es auch ganz wichtig, dass man sich irgendwie dessen bewusst ist, wenn man eben sagt, die Sprache ist ganz leicht zu verstehen oder irgendwas ist besonders schwer oder einfach oder so, dass man immer im Kopf hat, dass Leute mit ganz verschiedenen Vorwissen an solche oder ans Programmieren überhaupt rankommen und dass das vielleicht auch demotivieren kann. Und ich tatsächlich auch manchmal da sitze und dachte, jetzt sitze ich da seit einem Jahr und hab's immer noch nicht verstanden. Und alle sagen, es ist total leicht. Genau. Und ich dann denke, okay, ist es vielleicht doch nicht das Richtige für mich, soll ich damit aufhören?
Da würde ich jetzt gerne zu dem Punkt mit der Hürde kommen, den ich vorhin angesprochen habe, weil das halte ich auf ein ganz, ganz, ganz wichtiges Problem. Mich erinnert das, ich habe früher im Studium sozusagen mal die wilde Idee gehabt, Mathe im Nebenfach zu studieren. War in der ersten Vorlesung und dann ist sozusagen zwei Stunden lang passiert, dass der Professor gesagt hat, wie man leicht sieht, dann hat er so eine wilde Zahlenkarte, die wir angeschrieben haben. Ich hab nicht mal die Grundlage davon verstanden. Und dann hab ich so, okay, das ist nichts für mich. Und tatsächlich ist das auch, glaube ich, eine Schwierigkeit beim Programmieren. Man lernt die Einstiegskonzepte. Also man lernt irgendwie, wie man wohin springt, was eine Schleife ist und so. Und dann, also hab ich es so erlebt und ich kenne auch viele Leute, die von frisierter kommen, gibt es so einen Sprung auf einmal. Okay, jetzt kannst du das Ding, jetzt programmier doch mal den Klonkulator, der die Frumpturation im Speicherlieg kompromittiert. Und man weiß nicht mehr, wo es geht.
Das ist aber ein Problem, das ist eigentlich nur schlechte Didaktik. Das ist ja in vielen anderen Bereichen auch so, wenn du die so malst. Was war das vorhin, wie malt man eine Eule? W2-Kreise für die Augen, wie oben die Ohren ran und dann den Rest der Eule.
Ja genau. Aber so kommt man es beim Programmieren tatsächlich ganz viel vor. Auch wenn ich Online-Tutorials geklickt habe, war das oft so hier.
Das liegt dann aber glaube ich nicht an der Programmiersprache, sondern das ist das Tutorial-Ufer.
Genau, aber das ist ja anscheinend ein verbreiteter Effekt. Und die Frage ist natürlich, wie umgeht man den?
Gibt es eine Wissenschaft zu?
Also ein gutes Tutorial sollte natürlich immer so aufgebaut sein, dass der nächste Schritt ganz logisch auf den nächsten folgt. Also dass es wirklich die einfachste Möglichkeit ist, irgendwie von A nach B zu kommen. Und das ist, wie Erdgeist schon sagt, die Aufgabe vom Tutorial. Wenn das nicht hinbekommt, dann ist es nicht gut. Was ganz gut immer ist, finde ich, ist, wenn man sich vernetzt. Das machen wir auch beim Cola-Dojo, dass man immer Leute hat, die dabei sind oder die man mal fragen kann oder wo man sich einfach mal Rat holen kann, weil man oft an irgendeiner Kleinigkeit sitzt, wo man sich vielleicht viel zu viel Gedanken macht. Und in Wirklichkeit ist es aber ganz einfach und man kann jemanden fragen und der kann einem dann weiterhelfen.
Aber das heißt eigentlich sozusagen, den Beteiligten an diesem Ding, ich würde dir jetzt zwei bitten. Das eine ist sagen, liebe Programmier-Lerner-Anfänger, traut euch zu fragen. Liebe Programmier-Könner, bitte sagt nicht als allererstes, es ist doch ganz einfach.
Ich will immer den Leuten noch Mut machen. Ich will sagen, es ist nicht schwer und ihr könnt es auf jeden Fall.
Ja, das ist glaube ich auch was anderes zu sagen, du kannst das, ne? Und dass du irgendwie als Mentorin, als Mentor irgendwie an die Leute herantrittst und sagst, ich gebe dir jetzt das hundertprozentige Vertrauen, du kannst programmieren. Du musst da halt hinkommen irgendwie, aber du kannst das. Und das andere ist zu sagen, das ist total leicht.
Ich finde da gerade noch ein wichtiger Punkt angesprochen worden, der diese Community, die einen bei der Hand nimmt, die gibt es ja nicht nur für Leute, die dir jetzt explizit Programmieren beibringen, sondern auch als Nebeneffekt, dass du dich an Open Source Projekten beteiligst. Es gibt Communities für größere Projekte, wo man sich einbringen kann, ohne eine Zeile Code zu schreiben, indem man zum Beispiel Übersetzungen macht, indem man Dokumentationen nachliest und sagt, hier, das hat nicht verstanden. Und dann sagt, du Programmierer, das habe ich nicht verstanden, erklär mal nochmal anders. Und so eins der größeren Betriebssysteme FreeBSD macht es genauso, die lockt dort auch potentielle Programmierer an, indem sie sagt, ey, beteilige dich erstmal mit UserDoku für die Werkzeuge. Und wenn du dann diese Tools zum Programmieren grob beherrschst, dann guck mal, muss es ja nicht nur UserDoku sein, sondern auch die Kommentare im Code selber. Kannst ja mal gucken, ob du die verstehst. Wenn nicht, machst du Anmerkungen. Und so locken die seit 15 Jahren erfolgreich Programmierer in ihre Sphären. Weil wenn du dann erstmal dabei bist und den Code versuchst zu verstehen, indem du die Dokumentation liest, dann kannst du auch sagen, aber das stimmt auch nicht über einen. Dann muss man diese Zeile noch mit ändern und dann bist du plötzlich mitten beim Programmieren, ohne dass du es gemerkt hast.
Okay, also was übrigens immer zwischendurch immer wieder durchklingt, ist zu sagen, wenn man nicht für sich selbst programmiert, dann muss man Code auch, also Programmiercode, den man geschrieben hat, auch kommentieren. Also so hinschreiben, dass man ihn lesen kann. Wir haben jetzt einen Steffen am Telefon, der, ich weiß nicht genau, was uns gleich erzählt wird, aber er programmiert zumindest auch. Hallo und guten Abend Steffen.
Hallo, ich hab eure Sendung nicht von Anfang an mitgehört. Ich programmiere zum Beispiel HPV.
Nee, was ist das?
Das ist eine grafische Postmiersprache, analog zu LabView. Die ist in den 90er Jahren aufgekommen von Hewlett Packard. Die heißen jetzt Agilent oder Keysight. Die Entwicklungsumgehung läuft halt noch. Ich hab das auf Arbeit gebraucht, weil wir die Spektrumanalysatoren und die elektronischen Geräte von HP haben. Und da war halt schon mal die Kommunikation zwischen Rechner und Geräte sehr gut geregelt halt. Und davor hab ich in der Schule CC++ gelernt. Und ich hab dann Commodore am Anfang, hab HP Besig auch gemacht. Und eigentlich bin ich halt Elektroniker. Und ich sag halt immer, das Gute ist, um programmieren zu lernen, ist halt Motivation zu haben, zum Beispiel auf Arbeit, dass man irgendwelche Dinge, die einen echt ankotzen, durch Programmierung erleichtern kann. Zum Beispiel in meinem Fall ist es, ich bin halt Messtechniker. Und wenn man überlegt, man macht eine ganze Messreihe mit 50 Dateien. Und als ich angefangen hab, musste ich die Dateien alle einzeln zusammenfassen. Oder ich musste die in Excel darstellen und mehrere Dateien in Excel reinkopieren. Und dann hat man halt die Motivation, das zu automatisieren. Und das treibt einen ganz gut voran.
Die besten Programmierer sind die faulsten Schweine.
Ja, das ist total sinnvoll.
Und ich würde sagen, ich sitze heute noch davor und freue mich, wenn die Funktion einfach läuft.
Aber was würdest du jemandem empfehlen, der jetzt Programmieren von Null auf Lernen will? Wie soll ich das am besten anfangen? Was für ein Tipp hast du für diese Leute?
Ja, die Frage ist natürlich, es gibt ja ganz viele Bereiche, wo man programmieren kann. Ich denke mal, der, der anfangen soll, der muss auch irgendwo die Motivation haben. Dass er halt irgendwas Sinnvolles damit anfangen kann. Als ich zum Beispiel einen Commodore hatte, habe ich mir auch ein Programmierbuch gekauft mit Basic. Und da bin ich einfach dann hängen geblieben, weil ich habe dann irgendeinen Sprite programmiert oder so einen springenden Punkt. Aber dann habe ich gedacht, das ist ja nichts Sinnvolles. Dann bin ich halt damals als Jugendlicher davon wieder abgekommen halt. Dann habe ich wie gesagt in der Technikerschule dieses C++ so ein bisschen gemacht. Und dann konnte man halt ein paar Rechenbeispiele und Textboxen und dann konnte man so ein paar Sachen halt machen. Aber den richtigen Schub hatte ich dann halt erst durch die Arbeit bekommen halt. Und da hatte ich dann in der Technikerschule, da hatte ich halt Lab für gelernt. Auf Arbeit habe ich dann die andere Grafische Programmiersprache. Aber man hat dann auf jeden Fall ein Ziel, was man erreichen will halt. Und ich sage jetzt mal so, zum Beispiel wenn man Anfänger ist vielleicht und man hat mit Excel zu tun als Schüler oder als Kind, dann muss man vielleicht auch Diagramme formatieren oder andere Sachen. Und das sind ja immer viele Klicks, die immer gleich sind. Also kann man vielleicht anfangen, ein Makro aufzuzeichnen und dann ein Makro zu schreiben halt auch.
Also Stefan sagt, man soll, wenn man programmieren anfängt, immer ein Ziel haben und es lohnt sich tatsächlich auch, faul zu sein. Und wenn ich das so erdgeißig verstanden habe, kann er das bestätigen. Als Programmiermotivation. Na gut, dann machen wir an dieser Stelle nochmal eine kleine Pause für die Nachrichten und dann für die Nerd-News und reden danach nochmal ganz konkret darüber, wie man das jetzt oder womit man das anfangen kann, programmieren zu lernen.
Als er noch klein und unbekannt war, spielte er vor einer Handvoll von euch ein lauschiges Radiokonzert in den Fritz-Studios. Und schon damals haben wir gesagt, Und was haben wir gehabt? Recht haben wir gehabt. Fritz präsentiert Ed Sheeran Live in Berlin Montag, 27. März Ed Sheeran Live in der Bands Arena Ed.
Sheeran US-Präsident Trump will den Bau der Mauer an der Grenze zu Mexiko durch Strafzölle finanzieren. Auf alle mexikanischen Waren solle ein Zoll von 20 Prozent erhoben werden, sagte Trumps Sprecher am Abend. Auf diese Weise könnten jährlich 10 Milliarden Dollar eingenommen werden, womit sich der Grenzwahl leicht bezahlen lasse. Der mexikanische Präsident Nieto hatte vorher ein Treffen mit Trump abgesagt. Er will die Milliardenkosten für den Bau der Mauer nicht übernehmen. Der Bundestag hat den Bundeswehreinsatz im westafrikanischen Mali verlängert. Alle Fraktionen mit Ausnahme der Linken stimmten dafür, dass künftig bis zu 1000 deutsche Soldaten in Mali stationiert werden. Bisher waren es 650. Die UN-Mission gilt zurzeit als gefährlichster Einsatz der Bundeswehr. Auch die Ausbildungsmission im Nordirak wurde verlängert. Bei seinem Abschiedsbesuch in Frankreich hat Bundesaußenminister Steinmeier vor den Gefahren des Populismus in Europa gewarnt. Die bevorstehenden Präsidentschaftswahlen in Frankreich seien nicht nur für Frankreich wichtig, sondern für ganz Europa, sagte Steinmeier am Abend in Paris. Laut aktuellen Umfragen dürfte die rechtsextreme Marine Le Pen im Mai in die Stichwahl um die französische Präsidentschaft einziehen. An seinem letzten Abend im Ministeramt wurde Steinmeier in Paris mit dem Verdienstorden der französischen Ehrenlegion ausgezeichnet. Nach dem Fall Holm sollen alle Abgeordneten des neuen Berliner Landesparlaments auf eine frühere Stasi-Mitarbeit geprüft werden. Einen entsprechenden Antrag haben die Koalitionsfraktionen SPD, Linke und Grüne gestellt. Die Abgeordneten müssen aber zustimmen, dass sie überprüft werden. Vor 10 Tagen war Andrej Holm nach nur 5 Wochen im Amt des Baustartsekretärs zurückgetreten. Er hatte falsche Angaben über seine Stasi-Vergangenheit gemacht. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen im Berlin-Köpenick minus 2 Grad und in Charlottenburg minus 1 Grad, in Frankfurt-Oder und Brück minus 3 Grad, in Prenzlau minus 2 Grad und in Küritz minus 1 Grad. Am Abend und in der Nacht gibt es ein paar Wolken am Himmel, es bleibt aber meist trocken. Nachts kann es noch auf bis zu minus 10 Grad abkühlen, morgen früh ist es erst ziemlich neblig. Später kommt aber auch mal die Sonne durch, bei Temperaturen zwischen 0 und 3 Grad. Auf der A115 ist im Dreieck Funkturm die Überleitung zur A100 Richtung Wedding wegen Arbeiten an einer Brücke bis ca. 2 Uhr nachts gesperrt. Und auf der A10 südlicher Berliner Ringen Richtung Dreieck Werder gibt es zwischen Dreieck Nutetal und Färch an einer Nachtbaustelle bis 5 Uhr früh nur eine freie Spur. Außerdem fährt in Berlin die U-Bahnlinie 6 bis Ende des Monats nicht zwischen den Bahnhöfen Wedding und Kurt Schumacherplatz. Stattdessen könnt ihr den Bus nehmen. Ein unterwegs, ne gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RWB.
Und zum Chaosradio gehören auch die Nerd-News, beschrieben vom Chaos Computer Club, präsentiert von Johanna Tesma.
US-Präsident Trump hat den Netzneutralitätskritiker Ajit Pai zum Vorsitzenden der Regulierungsbehörde Federal Communications Commission berufen. Pai ist Gegner der Netzneutralitätsregeln, die sein Vorgänger Tom Wheeler gegen den Widerstand der Industrie durchgesetzt hatte. Laut Pai soll die Politik nur im Notfall eingreifen, denn Regulierungspolitik müsse sich an der Realität des Marktes orientieren. Union plant Pflicht zur Richtigstellung von Fake News. Die CDU-CSU-Bundestagsfraktion will soziale Netzwerke verpflichten, ihren Nutzern Richtigstellungen anzuzeigen, wenn der Nutzer zuvor Nachrichten gesehen hat, die als gefälscht identifiziert worden sind. Facebook plant lediglich, dass Nutzer einen Warnhinweis angezeigt bekommen sollen, wenn sie Fake News teilen wollen. Nach den Unionsplänen sollen auch nachträglich alle Nutzer, die Fake News angezeigt bekommen haben, darüber informiert werden. Das meldet der Spiegel. Chaos Computer Club im Visier der Geheimdienste. Die Bürgerrechtsorganisation Büro Jansen & Jansen berichtet, dass der niederländische Inlandsgeheimdienst AIVD versucht, Informanten anzuwerben, die deutsche Hacker-Spaces ausspionieren sollen. Eine betroffene Person sagte der Organisation, sie solle den Auftrag bekommen, die Hacker-Spaces des Chaos Computer Clubs zu besuchen und dem AIVD Interna zu berichten. Eine Sprecherin des Geheimdienstes dementierte das gegenüber netzpolitik.org. Linus Neumann, Sprecher des Chaos Computer Clubs, sagte, die Quellen des Chaos Computer Clubs beim AIVD hätten schon im Voraus Warnungen ausgesprochen. Deswegen sei man nur mäßig überrascht. Der Chaos Computer Club freue sich aber, dass ein weiterer Versuch der Unterwanderung an den hohen moralischen Prinzipien der Community gescheitert sei.
Und wenn ihr am Sonntagnachmittag zocken und lachen wollt, dann macht das doch bei den Sonntagsfritzen mit Kathrin Thüring und Jakob Lund und mit mir, dem Stimulator. Immer sonntags ab 14 Uhr auf Fritz.
Fritz Heute Chaosradio in Blumun noch eine halbe Stunde reden wir über das Programmieren lernen und zu Gast sind Marie, Nana und Erdgeist. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück! Wir haben ja schon über verschiedene Dinge gesprochen, die alle zu wiederholen jetzt zu lange dauern würde, deswegen hört euch den Podcast an unter fritz.de oder chaosradio.ccc.de, der am Laufe der Nacht noch erscheinen wird. Zu den verschiedenen Programmiersprachen ist noch eine Frage über die Studiomessage reingekommen und zwar Borland Delphi. Anscheinend wurde jemand damit geschlagen, wenn ich es richtig verstehe. Was ist das? Kann das? Was? Soll man das lieber wegwerfen?
Du bist halt auch alt. Also ich habe ja vorhin so eine Zeitlinie in die Vergangenheit mal aufgespannt für die letzten 15 Jahre. Das war noch davor.
Frühe 90er Jahre, ne? Das muss man jetzt nicht mehr lernen. Also wenn man jetzt anfängt...
Aber wenn man es kann, dann kann man mir schon dreihig werden.
Wieso?
Legacy Code. Also es gibt immer noch irgendwo was, was noch rumliegt, was in Delphi geschrieben ist. Aber jetzt als neue Sprache, nein.
Okay, jetzt ist es ja so, also gerade wenn man vielleicht noch in die Schule geht oder an der Uni gerade angefangen haben, dass dann so Dinge vorgesetzt werden, wo man so denkt, oh nein, bitte nicht. Aber gibt es dann sozusagen Tipps, wie man damit umgehen kann?
Das ist sehr schwer. Also viele von den Informatik-Ramenplänen, also den Lehrplänen, sind sehr alt, zum Teil über zehn Jahre alt und die werden auch nicht so schnell erneuert. Also das ist immer das Problem, dass das seine Zeit dauert, bis sich die Leute da geeinigt haben. Das heißt, man kann natürlich in der Schule, dann muss man vielleicht Delphi lernen. Das habe ich auch schon von Leuten gehört. Und das ist dann, da muss man eben diskutieren. Dann kann man vielleicht fragen, kann ich das Ganze auch in Java abliefern?
Also grundsätzlich sind wir wieder in den Bogen. Zum Anfang der Sendung ist ja Programmieren, das Lösen von Problemen und welches Werkzeug man dann benutzt, ist dem Informatik-Lehrer quasi egal.
Na, das halte ich tatsächlich für ein Gerücht.
Moment, wenn du das, ich hab's falsch formuliert, dass er dir grad ein Werkzeug aufzwingt, was du sonst nicht benutzen kannst, ist ihm egal, sondern er will, dass du das dann mal gerade in der Programmiersprache, wo er das Lösungsheft für hat, abliefert.
Das ist auch gemein den Lehrern gegenüber. Es steht tatsächlich in den Plänen drin, welche Sprachen man benutzen darf. Und da muss man sich eventuell mit arrangieren. Das ist leider nicht alles so leicht. Da gibt es auch für die Politik vielleicht als Anregung, ein bisschen schneller die Pläne erneuern.
So damit sind wir eigentlich schon auch beim Thema der letzten halbe Stunde. Man kann also primär in der Schule lernen. Das tut dann vielleicht weh. Ihr habt aber noch verschiedene Projekte und oder Webseiten oder Dinge mitgebracht, die einem das vielleicht einfach machen können. Bitte.
Ich kann mal nochmal was erzählen. Was immer sehr, sehr schön und lustig ist, auch wieder für Kinder und Jugendliche, ist Code Combat. Bei Code Combat kann man verschiedene Sprachen einstellen, zum Beispiel auch Python. Und man kann, es ist als Spiel aufgebaut, das heißt, man ist da, glaube ich, in so einer Fantasy-Welt. Man kann ein Ritter oder eine Ritterin sein und bewegt sich da so durch Verliese. Und man lernt gleichzeitig eben bestimmte Strukturen der Sprache. Man lernt, wie man irgendwie eine Schleife programmiert oder eine Bedingung oder sowas. Das ist sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr schön zu spielen und zu lernen. Es gibt...
Klingt nach einer Sache für mich.
Ja, es macht so viel Spaß.
Machst du was mit Spielen?
Vielleicht, manchmal?
Man kann auch JavaScript zum Beispiel damit lernen. Also vielseitig. Es gibt die Webseite code.org, die hat immer die Hour of Code, also eine Stunde programmieren, da gibt es... Das ist auch für kleinere Kinder geeignet. Da gibt es immer was mit Disney, mit Elsa und Anna oder mit, wie heißt dieser neue Film, Moana. Was mit Minecraft, alles Mögliche. Das ist für die kleineren Kinder ganz hübsch. Sollten allerdings schon ein bisschen lesen können. Haben wir noch was für die Älteren auch?
Na, für die Älteren gibt es im Internet tatsächlich, glaube ich, sehr viel am Tutorials. Und es gibt für Ruby, wie ein Wunder, das trialruby.org, also einfach zusammengeschrieben probierruby sozusagen auf englisch, trialruby.org. Und das ist wirklich ein sehr, da kannst du auch danach noch nicht wirklich richtig Ruby, aber es vermittelt dir so ein erstes Gefühl dafür, wie das funktionieren kann. Das heißt, es sagt dir ganz genau, was jetzt gerade passiert, und du tippst das einfach nur ab, was dir vorgegeben wird und siehst dann, wie das sozusagen, diesen Code, den du eingibst, was dabei halt herauskommt, was das Resultat ist. Und das kann so eine sehr einfach, aus meiner Perspektive, sehr einfache spielerische Art sein, sich damit überhaupt mal auseinanderzusetzen. Also wirklich ein Einstiegslevel. Es gibt dann aber auch eben Tutorials, also praktisch eigentlich ganze Bücher, die online stehen, zum Beispiel learnrubythehardway.org.
Das klingt ja total schmeichelhaft.
Ja, das ist auch, also klar, es gibt Leute, die sagen, ich finde das nicht so schlau, wenn man sagt, learn it the hard way. Das ist ein bisschen abschreckend. In dem Fall geht es aber darum, dass man tatsächlich kleinteilig vorgeht und nicht davon ausgeht, dass irgendwie die Leute schon sehr viel Vorwissen mitbringen. Es gibt viele Tutorials, die irgendwie auch eigentlich schon annehmen, dass du schon eine andere Sprache kannst und dass dann einfach irgendwie schon weißt, wie zum Beispiel so eine Schleife funktioniert oder andere Konzepte. Die haben mir immer nie geholfen, weil ich das eben nicht hatte so.
Ich glaube, eins bei dem The Hard Way ist auch der Aspekt, dass man die Sachen tatsächlich selber abtippen muss und soll. Du lachst, aber es ist tatsächlich sehr verbreitet heutzutage. Das mache ich natürlich niemals, dass man Sachen copy und pastet, ohne sie wirklich abzutippen oder auch zu verstehen. Und es funktioniert tatsächlich besser. Man lernt es besser, wenn man es selber tippt.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also ich kann schon sozusagen den Ansatz verstehen, dass man sagt, du lernst es, wenn es einmal durch deine Finger gefloßen ist. Aber wenn der Archetyp des faulen Programmierers auf einen Leitfaden stößt, der ihn zwingt, Programmcode abzutippen, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es dazu Interessen konzentriert.
Du kannst ganze Programmiererkarrieren drauf aufbauen, einfach nur von dieser Stack Overflow Community Seite. Ich kenne gleich Programmierer-Spiele, einfach raus zu kopieren und deinen Code einzufügen. Dann hast du gewonnen. Stack Overflow ist eine Webseite von Programmierern für Programmierer. Einfach so ein Forum im Web, wo man Fragen stellt und Bonuspunkte bekommt, wenn man die richtige oder als richtig akzeptierte Antwort gegeben hat.
Es gibt immer so diesen Spruch, wenn Stack Overflow down ist, dann haben alle Programmierer früher frei.
Ich dachte, da müssen sie länger arbeiten.
Nein, dann müsste man ja was selber machen.
Aber sag mal, das bringt mich zu einem Punkt, weil es taucht immer wieder auf, wenn man also Libraries oder sucht sich auf dieser Stack Overflow-Seite vielleicht Dinge und kopiert die dann. Ist das tatsächlich eine Empfehlung? Also ist das auch oder andersrum gesagt, ist das ist das Teil der praktischen Programmierarbeit, dass man eigentlich nicht sozusagen alles selber schreibt, sondern dass der größere Teil eigentlich ist, okay, ich brauche eine Problemlösung und dann gucke ich, was davon alles schon gemacht wurde, stecke das zusammen und sorge für die ordentliche Verbindungsstücke?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Es macht auch Sinn, weil oft haben die Leute, die die Libraries geschrieben haben, auch wirklich Arbeit und Kopf da reingesteckt und machen es so, wie es richtig ist. Und das, gerade wenn man so jetzt sicherheitsrelevante Sachen irgendwie ausprobiert oder so, man denkt, oh, ich könnte es ja so und so machen, aber das haben ganz viele andere Leute schon gedacht.
Ich finde es wichtig, dass du es ansprichst, weil das ist gerade eines der großen Probleme, das ist für mich das GitHub-Problem. GitHub ist so eine Seite, die es einfach macht, Programme, die man selber geschrieben hat, im Internet mal zu verbreiten und kollaborativ mit anderen Leuten an seinem Projekt weiterzuarbeiten. Und da ist eine große Gefahr da drin, weil da einfach keine Qualitätssicherung passiert. Und jeder und sein Hund haben natürlich irgendwann früher mal eine Bibliothek geschrieben, um Datumsformate ineinander überzuführen, um zu gucken, was für ein Wochentag war der, der ja nur 1970, keine Ahnung, haben Leute hingeschrieben, sich gefreut, oh super, hab ich verstanden, veröffentlichen das und andere Leute benutzen das. Und das ist ein großes Problem, weil das, was ich damals programmiert hab, als ich noch klein war, das hat glücklicherweise nie das Licht der Öffentlichkeit entdeckt. Da ist bis jetzt auch der gädige Gott des Bitrotts ist da drüber gegangen und auf das Ketten, die man nicht mehr lesen kann, ist das weg. Und heutzutage, wenn du als 12- 13-Jähriger anfängst zu programmieren und du wirst dazu animiert, das auf diese Seiten hochzuladen, jemand anders kommt vorbei, sieht, oh, da hat jemand mein Problem gelöst, nimmt diese Bibliothek und benutzt sie in seinem Projekt und scheitert dann an den lustigsten Stellen. Deswegen ist es doll wichtig zu wissen und jemanden zu haben, der einem hilft, dabei einzuschätzen, welche Bibliotheken...
Woran erkenne ich, dass die Bibliothek gut ist?
Leider nicht gerade. Es ist gerade echt schwierig, da musst du wirklich jemanden kennen, von dem du die Meinung gebildet hast, dass er sich so ein bisschen auskennt. Und vielleicht alle großen Frameworks, alle Programmiersprachen haben sogenannte Best Practices. Also Stand der Dinge, Guides zusammengestellt, wo sie bestimmte Bibliotheken empfehlen. Das funktioniert in einigen Programmiersprachen besser als in anderen. Ich darf keine Programmiersprachen bashen jetzt gerade, deswegen halte ich mich zurück.
Gut, dann können wir vielleicht noch zu einem positiven Punkt kommen, weil jetzt habt ihr gerade sozusagen dieses Wo, Womit oder Wo kann man programmieren lernen. Habt ihr Webseiten aufgezählt. Aber ich habe am Anfang der Sendung oder zwischendurch wieder gab es so, es gibt diese Veranstaltung, da kann man hinkommen, ohne irgendeine Ahnung zu haben. Also irgendwie Rail Scouts war sowas. Da würde ich zum Beispiel gerne mal wissen, wie läuft denn die konkret ab? Also ich meine, das ist ja schön, dass du sagst, man kann da hinkommen, muss keine Ahnung haben, hinterher kann man irgendwie programmieren. Aber wie genau läuft denn so ein, weiß ich nicht, Tag, Workshop, was auch immer?
Wie läuft das ab? Also in Berlin haben sie tatsächlich ein sehr schönes Konzept einfach erarbeitet und so ein Workshop findet eigentlich immer Samstag statt. Und Freitagabends wird immer schon am Vorabend angeboten, dass man eben sich trifft zur Installation von den Tools, die man dann am nächsten Tag braucht. Und manchmal, damit eben die Zeit da nicht weggenommen wird. Und da kann man sich schon so ein bisschen vorbereiten, ein bisschen kennenlernen. Und am nächsten Tag findet dann so ab, weiß ich nicht, zehn oder so, tatsächlich findet das eigentlich meistens so statt, dass man irgendwie ankommt, seine Gruppe findet, die Coaches dazu findet. Und dann gibt es irgendwie so eine Einführung in was ist vielleicht, was ist eigentlich Programmieren oder so grundsätzliche Konzepte. Zum Beispiel auch, wie funktioniert eigentlich so ein HTTP-Anfrage, ne? Wenn wir irgendwie eine Webseite ansteuern, was passiert da eigentlich? Also so Grundkonzepte. Und dann geht es darum, dass man sich ein Tutorial anschaut, Stück für Stück da durchgeht, in der Gruppe oder vielleicht auch alleine, je nachdem, und dann eben an so einer Rails-App so ein bisschen rumbastelt. Und am Ende, so ist das Tutorial aufgebaut, am Ende hat man dann eben so ein Resultat, was man sehen kann. Dann hat man so eine Karte, so eine Weltkarte, und dann kann man irgendwie, glaube ich, den Namen oder kann man irgendwie so Punkte draufsetzen oder so. Und zwischendurch gibt es dann noch so ein bisschen so Input-Talks von eben Programmierern, die dir eben sagen, irgendwelche Tipps geben oder sagen, wie man am besten irgendwie weiter lernen kann.
Genau.
Und danach, und das ist auch das Schöne daran, weil es ja tatsächlich dann eigentlich nur ein Tag wäre und der ist dann vorbei, bilden sich dann immer solche Study Groups, die sich eben einmal in der Woche treffen und dann genau da ansetzen, wo eben aufgehört wurde an diesem Tag. Und dann geht man da so ein ganzes Tutorial Ruby durch, wo man irgendwie wirklich bei Null anfängt und dann Woche pro Woche weitergeht.
Aber wenn man zu dem Event hin gibt, sagt man auch, okay, ich mach diese Study Groups auch oder kann man das entscheiden?
Auf keinen Fall, nee. Also macht man, wie man mag. Das wird halt dann eben angeboten, gesagt, hey, es gibt wieder eine neue, die eben wieder bei Null anfängt.
Das Coda Dojo, wie genau funktioniert das?
Coda Dojo ist immer ein Nachmittag. Die Kinder oder Jugendlichen kommen vorbei, dann sagen wir kurz was an und wir zeigen die Tutorials. Wir haben so eine Materialsammlung, die ist auch unter codadojo.com. Bei den Berliner Dojos und beim Potsdamer Dojo zumindest gibt es so eine Liste zu finden. Und dann geht's los. Also dann kann man wirklich schon gleich anfangen und man kann das machen, was man möchte. Wenn man keine Idee hat, kann man mal fragen, was könnte ich denn machen? Und dann, es ist selbst gesteuert und selbst organisiert. Das heißt, man macht das, wozu man Lust hat. Und solange man Lust hat. Und am Ende kann man vielleicht dann nochmal zeigen oder präsentieren, wenn man möchte, was man so gebaut hat. Was auch noch eine Sache ist, die ich erwähnen wollte, ist, dass wenn jetzt jemand sagt, oh, das ist eine großartige Idee, ich möchte das gerne in meiner Stadt auch machen, es gibt es aber noch nicht. Das könnt ihr euch einfach an uns wenden, weil jeder kann ein Coda-Dojo eröffnen. Es ist immer kostenlos. Ansonsten braucht man nur einen Raum. Aber in Berlin haben wir mehr Räume, als wir tatsächlich füllen können. Also wenn jemand sagt, ich kann schon ein bisschen programmieren, ich würde gerne mal aushelfen, oder jemand hat Kinder und will, dass die zum Coda-Dojo kommen können, einfach mal uns kontaktieren, und wir können auch beim Einstieg helfen. Oder man kommt einfach so vorbei, was auch total super ist.
Ich muss jetzt mal wieder meine Lanze für Python brechen, dass das Äquivalent zu diesen Ruby-Workshops gibt es auch mit Django Girls, was eigentlich genauso strukturiert ist und in diversen deutschen Städten stattfindet. Django ist ein auf Python basiertes Web-Framework, was ungefähr dieselbe Funktion erfüllt wie Rails für die Programmiersprache Ruby. Und die Python-Community hat sich auch eine Seite gegönnt, auf der diverse Tutorials für Programmierer und für Nicht-Programmierer drinstehen, wie man mit der Sprache anfängt. In dem Wiki sucht man nach Beginners Guide für Programmers oder Non-Programmers. Übersichtliche Liste auch kommentiert, welche gut und welche schlecht sind. Und das hilft dann beim Einstieg in die Programmiersprache Python.
Ich würde noch zwei befreundete Projekte ganz gerne erwähnen. Und zwar einmal, wenn man als Jugendlicher jetzt schon ein bisschen mehr Ahnung hat, schon ein bisschen fortgeschrittener ist, kann man sich mal die Seite von Jugendhackt anschauen, wenn man das noch nicht gemacht hat. Das ist ein wunderbares Projekt. Das gibt im Jahr mehrere Hackathons, wo man mit anderen Jugendlichen zusammenarbeitet, Projekte macht, um die Welt zu verbessern. Ganz großartiges Projekt, Jugendhackt.de. Zweites Projekt, was auch in Berlin gibt, ist die Hearts of Code.
Das wollte ich doch sagen. Die Hearts of Code ist ein Projekt, das vor ungefähr über einem Jahr geboren wurde in Berlin. Das ist eine Initiative, um einen Hackspace für Personen, die sich als Frauen identifizieren, gründen wollen. Im Moment treffen wir uns jeden Donnerstag, so auch heute Abend, im befreundeten X-Hain. Das ist ein Hackspace in Friedrichshain. Da kommen eigentlich immer Frauen vorbei, die sich irgendwie für Technik begeistern und interessieren. Das heißt, da kann man auch unabhängig von einem Workshop oder von einem Event, was vielleicht gerade nicht stattfindet, kann man sich einfach treffen und sagen, hey, ich hab Lust, das und jenes zu machen. Gibt's da nicht jemanden. Da gibt es mittlerweile schon eine ganz stolze Communitygruppe, die sich eben vernetzt und über die man dann eben Gleichgesinnte treffen kann.
Die machen auch immer so tolle Events, wie zum Beispiel wir gehen zusammen in die Seabase oder weil es auch einfacher ist zusammen irgendwo hinzugehen, wenn man sich vielleicht noch nicht so richtig traut. Oder wir machen eine Krypto-Party, wo man lernen kann, was Verschlüsselung bedeutet oder so. Für Frauen, Sternchen.
hardofcode.org oder auf Twitter einfach Hardofcode.
Ist das nicht Hackerinnen?
Ok. Ich will nicht mensplain, aber wir haben jetzt Veranstaltungen für Kids und Jugendliche und für Frauen und solche, die sich als solche identifizieren. Wird davon ausgegangen, Männer können einfach hacken? Oder gibt es auch Events, die genau mit dem Anspruch, ich kann nicht programmieren und ich möchte auch nicht, dass ich ausgelacht werde, weil ich nicht programmieren kann, sagen, wo man das lernen kann?
Da haben wir vorhin drüber geredet und wir wussten nicht so genau.
Na ja, es gibt halt die Open Tech School, die gibt es ja. Das ist einfach auch, würde ich sagen, so eine Initiative oder so eine Community, über die man alle möglichen Workshops eben besuchen kann. Ich habe da zum Beispiel mal einen Einstieg in CSS besucht. Die bieten alles Mögliche an, auch Einstieg in funktionale Programmierung. Und das ist offen für Frauen, Männer und alle dazwischen. Also insofern, ja, es gibt halt immer noch in der Informatik, soweit ich weiß, der aktuelle Stand ist 17% Frauenanteil. Deswegen gibt es da schon auch, das kommt nicht von, wie sagt man, von ungefähr. Das ist so viele Angebote, oder sagen wir mal, dass es ein paar Angebote gibt, die eben für Frauen sind.
Die wollt ihr euch gar nicht in Abrede stellen. Das ist eine technische Frage. Also wenn man halt einfach keine Ahnung hat und sich jetzt diese Sendung hört, denkst du so, hey, das klingt total geil.
Du meinst, wenn man so 35-jähriger Radiomoderator ist?
29, 29.
Eines, was mir noch einfällt, ist ja Minigame Jam. Den gibt es auch in Berlin. Das ist nicht immer nur Computerspiele, sondern generell Spiele entwickeln. Die sind auch sehr nett eigentlich. Wenn man sich jetzt für Computerspiele interessiert ist.
Und da kann man auch hingehen, ohne programmieren zu können? Weil man das sozusagen...
Weil man einfach nur eine Idee hat oder mal gucken möchte oder so.
Es gibt auch alle möglichen User Groups. Und da denke ich, wenn man da mal hingeht und sagt, hey, ich hab Lust, das zu lernen, da trifft man bestimmt auch auf offene Ohren. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Stimmt, so Linux User Groups, die sind wie ganz vorne dabei. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du da irgendjemanden triffst, der irgendeine Programmiersprache beherrscht und dich da mal bei der Hand nimmt, ist nicht so gering.
Okay, dann wissen wir Bescheid, warum haben wir besprochen, was haben wir besprochen und wo haben wir jetzt auch besprochen. Jetzt haben wir noch ein paar Minuten Zeit und entweder könnt ihr jetzt noch ein flammendes Abschlussplädoyer fürs Programmieren lernen halten oder ihr erklärt mir, was es mit den 99 Bierflaschen auf sich hat. Eure Wahl. Ich habe noch nie ein so unsicheres Fragen nach einem flammenden Plädoyer gehört. Aber bitte, los geht's! Das flammende Plädoyer von Nana.
Also programmieren. Man sollte auf jeden Fall keine Angst haben, programmieren lernen zu wollen. Es macht unglaublich viel Spaß. Es ist ein ganz toller Effekt, wenn endlich das passiert, was man immer wollte, das passiert. Ich finde immer, man sollte ein Projekt haben und man will es dann unbedingt bauen. Und da wird man dann auch irgendwie leichter über diese Hürden kommen, wo wir drüber gesprochen haben. Programmieren bedeutet Selbstermächtigung. Ich kann die Welt besser gestalten und ich kann sie auch besser verändern, wenn ich programmieren kann. Es muss sich ja nicht jeder können, aber es gibt, es macht das Leben schöner.
Wenn es nach mir ginge, sollte jeder programmieren lernen. Aber eigentlich ist es erstmal wichtig, grob zu verstehen, dass ein Computer oder die Computer, die man heute im Laden kaufen kann, quasi einen Schritt nach dem nächsten machen. Die holen sich Instruktionen, die man denen irgendwann mal beigebracht hat. Führen die aus, holen sich die nächste, führen die aus. Und da ist keine Magie dabei. Da ist höchstens irgendjemand dabei, der beim Programmieren eines einer Applikationen mal bestimmte Dinge nicht bedacht hat. Und dadurch unnötige Komplexität erzeugt hat. Das heißt, da muss man keine Angst davor haben. Man ist im Zweifel nicht dumm, sondern man ist dort einfach nur leibtragender von dem, was ein Programmierer irgendwann mal falsch gemacht hat. Und man kann es eventuell in einigen Projekten besser machen, indem man sich, wenn man sich doll drüber ärgert, in den Code reinguckt, versucht zu verstehen, was da schief geht und sich vielleicht daran sogar beteiligt, wenn einem dieses Programm doll viel bedeutet.
Ja, ich hab vor zwei Jahren mir mal eine Menstruations-App runtergeladen und dann hat eine Freundin von mir gesagt, das kannst du nicht machen, die spähen deine Informationen aus, lösch die wieder. Ich fand die total toll, ich wollte diese App eigentlich gerne benutzen und war dann aber doch davon überzeugt und hab die App dann wieder gelöscht. Und hab jetzt im Laufe eben mit diesem ganzen Programmieren lernen und so vor glaube ich zwei oder drei Wochen angefangen, eine Open-Source-Mensurations-App zu mir anzuschauen, mir sozusagen den Code zu kopieren und werde das jetzt mit einer Freundin oder mit einer Mitstreiterin sozusagen mir anschauen. Hab eigentlich keine Ahnung von Android. Das ist eine Android-App, aber bin jetzt glaube ich mit dem Grund selbstbewusstsein ausgestattet, mir diese App einfach anzuschauen und munter rumzuhacken. Deswegen kann ich das deswegen auch sehr empfehlen.
Alles klar, löst eure Probleme, lernt, programmieren und hackt munter rum. Ich danke Erdgeist, Nana und Marie, die hier in Wanne übers Programmieren lernen gesprochen haben. Ich danke Dani Mo und Mo, die die Sendung organisiert haben und die NerdNews geschrieben haben. Ich danke Johanne Tesmer, die die NerdNews ganz hervorragend vorgetragen hat und uns durch die Nachrichten geleitet hat. Ich danke euch fürs Zuhören. Ihr könnt den Podcast nochmal runterladen unter fritz.de oder chaosradio.ccc.de Nach uns kommt Jan Schwarzkamp, der euch die Nacht mit Gitarrenmusik erfreuen wird. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich habe nur noch eine Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
I've clicked more than Douglas Engelbart.
I need the internet like Whitney Houston needs crack.
All my bitches up in the club. Let me see you shaking it, don't stop.
Rub it down, bounce around.
1, 2, Polizei, 3, 4, Voltaire, 5, 6, Pappetex, 7, 8, mit oder?
It's an index finger party.